guess what he's quoting alar to prove
that Jesus is only sent to the Jews
exactly it's ridiculous argument of I'm
I'm getting tired of it to be honest
with you bro yes go ahead let's deal
with it let's go to Matthew
15:24 if you so we're gonna we're gonna
take the common
silly objections of Muslim and by the
grace of the Lord Jesus Christ we're
going to use the very objections to
prove Muhammad is a false prophet so
let's begin Matthew 15:24 read that for
me so Matthew 15:24 reads he answered I
was sent only to the lost sheep of
Israel now L if I just read that verse
in
isolation if I just read that verse in
isolation then clearly the impression is
that Jesus Christ is not the savior of
the
world he's only sent to redeem Israel
however Matthew 15 is not the beginning
of the Gospel it's not the end of the
Gospel Matthew 15 is in the middle of
the Gospel there are 14 chapters that
preceded and then you have chapters 16
to 28 that come right after it so I'm
going to now read Matthew
15:24 in the context of Matthew to see
what Jesus meant and what Jesus did not
mean so guys embark on this journey with
me because I'm trusting the spirit to
use me and out to teach you our brothers
and sisters how to interpret the Bible
how not to interpret it and how then to
take this sword because the Bible is the
sword of the spirit because the Bible
says God's word which includes the Bible
because it's God's word is our sword
given to us by our spirit to use in
spiritual battle show you how to use
this sword for the glory of Christ
against Heretics and false prophets like
Muhammad now do me a favor go to Matthew
Matthew chapter 10
read verses 17 18 Matthew 10: 178 all
right we're going to go to Matthew 10
we're going to read 17 verse 17 says be
on your guard you will be handed over to
the local councils and be flogged in the
synagogues Verse 18 on my account you
will be brought before Governors and
Kings as witnesses to them and to the
Gentiles wait wait wait wait our Lord
Jesus Christ tells the disciples the
time will come that you'll be taken
before the rulers of the Gentiles to be
a witness to their rulers and a witness
to the Gentiles in other words Jesus has
already told them Jesus has already told
them in advance though I'm sending you
to the lost sheep of Israel the time
will come where your ministry will
extend beyond Israel to the Nations
because you'll be my mouthpieces my
instruments through which I reach the
Nations
for the gospel amen you see that right
that's what Jesus told them that's
exactly what he says oh okay but now
let's see what prophecy Jesus fulfills
our Lord fulfills an Old Testament
prophecy that shows that he is the
Father's servant who's not just the
savior of Israel but the savior of the
ends of the Earth a savior for all
Gentiles go to Matthew 12 read 17- 21
Matthew 12:
17-21 slowly but surely read it for us
brother all right starting from verse 17
this was to fulfill what was spoken
through Isaiah the prophet behold my
servant whom I have chosen my beloved in
whom my soul is well pleased I will put
my spirit upon him and he shall Proclaim
Justice to the Gentiles to who Gentiles
so Jesus is the servant of the father of
Isaiah 42 who will bring Justice to
Israel or to the Gentiles to the
Gentiles unless that the clown doesn't
know the difference between Gentiles and
Jews then he's obviously mixing the two
together oh but it gets even better keep
reading brother gets even better verse
19 he will not quarrel nor cry out nor
will anyone hear his voice in the
streets e battered readed he will not
break off and a smoldering Wick he will
not put out until he leads Justice to
Victory and in his name the Gentiles
were hope now read 21 one more time
Saints Listen to 21 Jesus fulfills
Isaiah
42:4 quoted in Matthew 12:21 and what
does it say Jesus will do read it one
more time and in his name the Gentiles
will hope
in his name the Jews will
hope no that's not what it says man I
don't know what Bible you're looking at
but so wait Matthew 12 which comes
before Matthew 15 Matthew 10 which comes
before Matthew 15 Matthew has already
prepared us for Jesus's Universal
Mission now I want you to go to Matthew
24 ver14 Matthew
24:4 Jesus speaking Matthew 24:14 this
is what he says this go El of the
Kingdom shall be preached in the whole
world as a testimony to all the nations
and then the end will come no wait read
it one more time Matthew 24:14 our lord
Jesus says what about his gospel this
Gospel of the Kingdom shall be preached
in the whole world as a testimony to All
Nations and then the end will come wait
the same Jesus who said I was sent only
to the lost sheep of Israel tells the
disciples my gospel of the Kingdom must
be proclaimed throughout the whole world
as a witness to All Nations not just the
Jews and this man had the audacity to
quote the very gospel that tells us
though Jesus himself came to the Jews on
earth when Jesus was physically on Earth
the physical Jesus who was on Earth
limited his ministry to the Jews but
after ascending to Glory he would send
out his disciples to all the nations oh
wow that's why now we need to go to
Matthew 28 verse 19 now guys don't
forget some of you already quoted
Matthew 28:19 Matthew 2019 this is now
the Risen Jesus the resurrected Jesus
the Jesus who died for sins raised
Immortal he's now in his flesh body a
body of Flesh that's now made Immortal
and before he enters Heaven here's the
commission to the disciples you
disciples are going to do this now on my
behalf Matthew 28: 19 so verse 19 this
is what he says go therefore and Make
Disciples of all
Nations baptizing him in the name of the
father and the Son and the Holy Spirit
okay how much clearer could Matthew be
how much clearer can our Lord be how
much clearer could the Old Testament be
Messiah Jesus comes to the Jews but he's
not just for the Jews so what did our
Lord mean and I want the Christians to
understand what our Lord meant in
Matthew 15:24 yes Jesus while on
Earth the historical Jesus while he's on
Earth he limited his Earthly Ministry to
the Jews why because the promises were
given to the Jews so since they are The
Heirs of the prophets The Heirs of the
Covenant Jesus is going to come to the
Jews and announce to them your Messiah
has come the promises are fulfilled turn
to me after he does that after he's
crucified and dies as a vicarious
sacrifice for our sins and he's raised
from the dead now he'll Empower his
disciples by his holy spirit which he'll
pour out on them to then take that
message that he preached to the Jews
throughout the whole world to all the
nations that's what Matthew 15:24 means
but now again because this Iron Stone
smoocher doesn't really care what
Matthew says he just wants to take
Snippets quot it out of context to try
to confuse us L does he realize the true
Jesus who is the Lord Of Glory has
raised up his Warriors to silence these
lies and turn arguments against them I'm
going to use this Quran now for the
Christians I want you to listen to this
this man again confirms David Wood's
words and David wood was in the comment
section David wood came out with a
session where he says Muslims are
apostatizing because Muslims are going
against the commands of Muhammad they're
apostates they pay lipice service
Muhammad says one thing Muslims say the
direct opposite thereby failing to
submit to Muhammad showing that they're
Hypocrites and unbelievers and so is
Iron Stone smoocher why do I say that
because the Quran says Jesus's Ministry
is for All Creatures not just for the
Jews so Christians are you ready for
those passages those proofs I'm just
going to limit myself to the Quran
because if I introduce the Hadith he's
going to get embarrassed even worse so
do me a favor can you go to Chapter 3 of
the Quran Iman chapter 3 read verses 3
and four so we will see in chapter 3
veres 3 and 4 whether the Gospel of
Jesus and even the Torah was it limited
only to the Y B is or was it given to be
light and guidance For All Mankind
chapter 3: 3 and 5 does it matter to you
which translation brother no brother
because you also know the Arabic and
you'll correct it if they're misquoting
that's true all righty we are going to
go
there so um we are going to go to uh
verse three y it is he who sent down to
you in truth the book confirming what
went before it and he sent down the law
and the gospel before this as a guide to
Mankind and no does it say to yah B is
or mankind mankind okay say it again so
the Torah and the
gospel a guide to mankind exactly you
can confirm the Arabic I'm going by
memory I believe here it
says it's the word Nas not right yeah
let me let me just make sure so nobody
can accuse us of doing anything funny I
don't want to just rely on my memory
even though I trust the Holy Spirit to
perfect my ability recall for the glory
of Jesus Christ and sanctifies to give
us the power to
yeah okay so it's the word Nas now you
know why that's important Al of course
it is Torah and the gospel given as
guidance to NAS mankind do me a favor go
toah Bak chapter 2 and read verse
185 Bak chapter 2 verse
185 will go go
there and we're going to read uh
Ramadan is the month in which was sent
down to uh down the Quran as a guide to
mankind once again don't go any further
Ramadan is the month in which the Quran
was sent down unto mankind Quran sent to
mankind guess what the word is there the
word
absolutely the same word the exact same
exact same phrase Quran was sent as a
guidance to mankind the Torah and the
gospel were sent down as guidance to
mankind now will Iron Stone smoocher say
the Quran was only sent to the Arabs
because there it says Quran was sent
down as
guidance for mankind which Blackstone
kisser would deny the cran was sent For
All Mankind but the exact phrase used of
the Torah and the gospel it says the
gospel like the Quran sent as guidance
for mankind so you see not only the
Gospel of Jesus the Torah also is For
All Mankind not just the Jews according
to the
Quran yeah according to the Quran it's
not to the Jews only to Mankind and
guidance guidance to mankind guidance
now but it gets worse for Iron Stone
smoocher because I want you to go to
chapter 19 verse 21 of the Quran
Chapter 19 Verse 20 21 what does it say
about Jesus he's a sign and in Mercy and
aah and sign and mercy for who
exactly exactly brother I just used this
argument recently uh here is what it
says and he said thus this is a
translation it will be your Lord says it
is easy for me and we will make him in
reference to Jesus a sign to the people
and a mercy from us and the word in the
Arabic so here it's Nas right he is a
miracle for Nas and a mercy unto the nas
right mank exactly exactly but wait wait
wait in
2191 it says he's not just a sign
to he's a
sign for all beings so if you now you go
to chapter
21 21: 91 is Jesus a sign for All
Creatures because the word
is yes look at it here and uh
translation says and remember her who
guarded her Chastity so we breathe into
her of our word and we made her and her
son a sign for All Peoples
so doesn't mean b it means all worlds
all creatures all beings exactly and
that's what exactly Muslims say that
Muhammad was
sent okay so did the Christians see how
Iron Stone smoocher proved Muhammad is a
false prophet because the Bible
specifically Matthew and the Quan teach
Jesus's gospels for All Creatures not
just the Jews and yet he wanted to
misquote Matthew to teach otherwise and
in so doing he proved Muhammad didn't
know what he's talking about so that the
stone smoocher is not even a good
muhammadin which is why he's now silent
where
is oh last we heard he changed the topic
that's it he's
gone what an ironic man isn't he so
ironically he provided an example of
many examples of some of the most common
silly objections raised by Muslims
against the Christian face so that's
what we're going to talk about and let
me know when we have to wind things down
okay that's what we're going to have to
talk about